c'est bien connu pour voir la vraie vie
dans une ville ou un village de france
il faut y venir un jour de marché au
teilleul c'est le jeudi
alors on s'est levés de bonne heure pas
la peine
en fait le marché ne bat son plein que
vers 11 heures
et là on n'avait pas de chance c'était
encore les vacances est mort les jeunes
ne viennent les marchés ont les créneaux
et sûrement rire en ville mais pas ici
là plus rien on connaît la chanson
c'était mieux avant on pourrait
l'entendre à tous les coins de rue dans
ce coin du sud-manche aux frontières de
l'orne et de la mayenne
ces quatre communes où on va passer
quatre jours à commencer par le teilleul
là-haut à deux pas de la place du marché
retrouvons et suivants guide c'est russe
est la sienne de pâles un jour ça c'est
une aisance certaine pâti du grand mère
de 93 ans et lui paul foucault à 87 ans
là c'est pareil
c'était un commerce à l'abri c'était un
ancien artisan marchand de vélos et le
pas-de-porte voisins c'était le sien
tissus et confection hommes et dames ça
fonctionnait bien
on est allé sur le trottoir et tout ça
moi je ferai la campagne et ma femme
tenait là avec sa mère un commerce du
20e siècle
ça a bien marché jusqu'en 92 après ça
commençait à décliner la population a
baissé puis les marchés l'immeuble est à
vendre aujourd'hui une bouchée de pain
quant à paul il demeure à côté de murray
n'est pas vraiment mots parce qu'il est
toujours en mouvement
jeux pour les nerfs pour l'association
aidée je m'occupe de la banque
alimentaire
après je travaille au centre social de
la mairie
il a été longtemps conseiller municipal
il reste fidèle à la commune au
quotidien
j'ai toujours été actif moi c'est
vraiment votre s'arrêter pour soi et
pour les autres en civil pour les autres
surtout il est coursier bénévoles il
nous emmène dans une mairie toute
pimpante qui a pour mot d'ordre la
revitalisation
autrement dit ne pas s'arrêter à tout ce
que l'on a vu depuis ce matin quand on
dit la revitalisation c'est l'habitat
les commerces la circulation la mobilité
donc l'objectif s'est relooké notre
centre bourg donc c'est un chantier
entre 15 et 20 ans nous avons beaucoup
d'habitations qui sont inoccupés
faute de confort quand on a des demandes
de location aux mairies c'est une
habitation un espace vert les projets
sont affichés dans l'ancienne maison de
la presse que la commune vient
d'acquérir tout le mal des campagnes ces
remèdes tiennent sur ces panneaux
inutile de courir après le lustre
d'antan les dix siècles d'histoire de
l'ancien baronnies normande et fief
agricole au coeur de son bocage
économiquement parlant
on a pris quand même quelque peu le
tournant de deûle et du poids de
l'agriculture qui s'amenuisent avec le
poids de
deux des activités industrielles ou
artisanales donc en fin de compte des
tilleuls a toujours évolué ça l'est
toujours sortir on va parler les gens
qui s'informent pas demain demain qui
sera un autre jour avec un nouvel
épisode